The answer is we want to make our discrening bear a subtype of the grizzly bear.
This allows us to reuse the grizzly bear code for knocking down a tree and
chasing a victim. The problem is inside chase when we eat the victim, we don't
want the bear eat behavior. We want the discerning bear to do something
different. So what this means is we need to define a new eat method inside
Discerning Bear, give it the behavior we want. So here's what the code for
discerning bear class looks like. The only method we need to define is eat,
everything else is inherited from Grizzly Bear or from Bear and what we do and
eat is check if the name if the victim is Dave. If it's not, we print something
and happy otherwise we eat the victim.